[Music]
to what extent are we making ourselves
miserable by expecting to find happiness
in one person or one person to check all
of these
boxes including romantic notions that
seem to have largely started in the
western world with troubadours and so on
i don't know if that's a coherent
question but since you have more
experience with these things than i do
i'd love to
hear you speak to that in any way
whatsoever
that's a deep question
kind of a hard one it's a great insight
that
a lot of marriages in the past were
either arranged
right by the parents
and
or
had
ulterior motives
even if it was just to get the crops in
i mean we're joking about economies of
scale but economy scale were not
unimportant in most of human history you
had kids partly to help you slop the
hogs i mean and milk the cows
right and to take care of when you get
old these were very pragmatic unromantic
ideas having said that
any
trip through western literature
you understand there's a little both
right you read shakespeare you read jane
austen jane austen's characters usually
are striving to make a advantageous
match
not a love match
but they also fall in love so that's one
of the reasons i think her books are so
uh compelling
they don't just want to be
pragmatic
but but it's a very deep question of
whether
what you should look for what you should
expect of marriage and and i think
hollywood misleads us a little bit
you know look across the room and
i've argued they're very few movies
that capture love right they're movies
that capture romantic attraction sexual
attraction
i'll give you an exception
my fair lady
not a very
pc or
you know politically correct movie in
modern times
but it's a fascinating portrait of how
henry higgins falls in love with eliza
doolittle despite himself right he
doesn't want to fall in love he sees his
bachelorhood life as an ideal kind of
like darwin actually and yet
he finds himself falling in love and um
you know it's one of the most beautiful
love songs ever written when you think
how do you capture that feeling of
[Music]
real love not just attraction
he says i've grown accustomed to her
face
what a magnificent magnificent line
right
her smiles her frowns her ups or downs
their second nature to me now
like breathing out and breathing in
like that's an incredible portrait of
domestic life right
yeah
my point being that
art
actually
pays some attention to this thing that
evidently has been around for a long
time it's not just about
sexual attraction it's about love and
romantic attraction or whatever you want
to call that a partnership
symbiosis to make it really as
undramatic as possible maybe even less
romantic than uh economies of scale at
costco
but i think to come back to the nub so
what should you look for what should you
expect you know and is it worth it is it
worth something is it something you
should strive for
i'll just say what you know we could
talk about this for the other five hours
but the one thing i would add
i don't like it when people say
you know you have to work at your
marriage
you have to work at it that's not the
way i think of my marriage
i work at crossword puzzles
i work at ditch digging i work at you
know
writing up my notes for my next podcast
but what you do have to do
is you have to treat your partner as a
partner
as opposed to somebody who you know is
lives with you who's blessed to have his
roommate
they're two different things and i think
in modern life we have not
we've taken away for a thousand reasons
the
responsibilities of marriage
and
and i think that's come at a cost right
and
it's made it harder for people to get
married if you look at the data it's
pretty obvious let's be uh scientific
for a minute
people are marrying later or not at all
it's changed
and does the appeal
comes back to the darwin point the
appeal of a long-term commitment
from the outside is mostly negative for
most people
i think certainly for most men
i don't know if women are different but
they uh seem to be it's not fashionable
to say that but i think they are
but men it's hard men struggle to stay
in a long-term relationship
and it's not as appealing to either side
it's pretty obvious
in the data so
what do you do
well tricky
could you say more about the
diminishing of the responsibilities of
marriage and what you mean by that
the part i like about you have to work
at your marriage is it it is hard
there are parts about marriage that are
hard there's parts about having a good
marriage that are difficult that are
challenging
there's a great line from
andy lamott
she says
her name for god
not
me right
and most of us
naturally
see ourselves as god center of the
universe most important thing
easy
and i think
one of the great advantages of marriage
is to remind you that it's not all about
you
and
you know some people find that appealing
and some people don't i think i took
this line out of the book but i have a
friend who said until you get married
his father told him this until you get
married you're an idiot
i feel that sometimes i think there's a
lot of truth to that and
living with another person is a
commitment
not as a contract very important
difference i talk about in the book it's
more of a covenant and less of a
contract
is really a powerful way to be alive
it's basically this is to enhance what i
said earlier about
what a real marriage is about it's not
about working at it oh let's have a
session where we talk about our you know
issues
it's about remembering because back to
what we said the very beginning this
conversation remembering things that are
very hard to remember
that you're in this together this other
person has a soul
a desire
a flavor a preference
and
that's hard because you have yours and
you know what i like getting what i want
don't you
yeah we do most of us most of the time
and to figure out how to mesh your plans
with your partner's plans
and not just what we're doing on sunday
night because we can take turns and
we'll do italian tonight next week we'll
do chinese but how to make a life
together is um
really hard and beautiful and deeply
rewarding if it goes well and when it
doesn't go well it's horrible by the way
i don't want to romanticize it at all
right it's horrible
awful stultifying
degrading
it's bad so it's a high risk game and to
come back to your earlier question
for most human history it wasn't a
choice it was a destiny it wasn't a
decision
you got married you had to you felt that
way anyway it doesn't feel that way
anymore whole new world
all right so i have a number of
follow-up questions and i'm not going to
spend
the next hour on marriage so don't worry
but i do have one clarifying question
which is until you're married you're an
idiot are you in does that refer to
being an idiot in the sense of being so
ego
centric and self-referential that you
just don't have
the sort of lens or experience of the
world that is as broad and more complete
as someone who has decided to partner
with someone else
yeah
yeah okay
that's it exactly
it's not the normal kind of i'll be
saying a slightly different way
i've come to believe as i've gotten
older
that a huge part of quote growing up
you know we like to joke hey tim what do
you do when you grow up you know like
like you still have room to grow well i
hope you do right we're not all grown
it's like shalom right you're not whole
you're not grown up
one of the funniest things in life is
you look at the people older than you
and you think when i'm their age i'll
feel the way they do and you get to that
age and you don't
right you look at the seniors in high
school when you're a sophomore
wow they're so confident and they seem
so at ease
i can't wait till i'm a senior then
you're a senior it's like
they were all faking it every one of
them
right
and it's a great thing i think to admit
that i'm not grown up i haven't figured
it all out i haven't not mature fully
more mature maybe than i was before but
i'm not mature it's hard
so
a lot of what
to me
of a life well lived is about growing up
and marriage is one way to grow up not
the only way there are other ways to
grow up
religion
meditation psychotherapy
marriage they're all about
self-awareness they're all if they're
done well they're all about recognizing
that you're part of a much bigger
picture than you feel like most of the
time
and i think that's really helpful and
incredibly satisfying when you sense it
it's great
you